Let's go to the phone lines at (617) 830-4750
starting today with our caller from the nine
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from nine one seven.
Hey David, this is Sebastian.
How are you?
Good.
Good, good, good.
So I live in Poland and I was going to look,
uh, look at your Twitch channel to watch the
debate from yesterday and it seems like it's
been blocked and I'm not sure if you're aware
of it.
Oh, believe me, I am aware of Sebastian.
So what happened is that the, the, our channel,
our stream and channel were taken down by
someone claiming to represent CBS, which broadcast
the debate.
And this happened as far as we can tell exclusively
to left wing streamers at the exact same time.
The email address listed for this company
called Praxis legal who did the takedown bounces
back.
It's a fake email.
The website for this company has just disappeared
from the internet and there is a legal investigation
happening as we speak, being conducted by
Twitch legal and attorneys that I've retained
into whether these are legitimate claims and
yes, it is.
We are in the middle of a mess right now with
regard to that.
Right.
Okay.
I just wanted to see, I wanted to send you
a message on Twitter, but I don't have an
account on [inaudible].
Oh yeah, no, we know.
We know.
We've got, we did an entire story on the show
about it and it's a mess and when we have
resolution, I will come to the audience and
say, we figured out what happened.
All right.
Thanks man.
Good job with the program.
All right.
Thank you so much, Sebastian.
Appreciate hearing from you, Sebastian, from
Poland.
Let me make a note.
We definitely want in our notes that Sebastian
is in Poland.